today we're going to talk about
externalities and we'll start with
simple theory so the theory of
externalities now as I've said before
the sort of fundamental mantra of most
discourses that markets know best
indeed as I said the first fundamental
theorem of welfare economics that
powerful sounding name is the conclusion
that the perfectly competitive private
market will deliver the welfare
maximizing outcome so standard economics
starts from the proposition the market
knows best in that world the government
can only screw things up okay all the
government does sort of mess up the
first best now either
despite this the government is in the
typical developed economy at least
typically 25 to 30 percent of the
economy is the government so either
these developed economies have it
totally wrong where there are some
reasons why we might actually depart
from the standard fortune one model and
think for reasons for government now we
didn't cover one which was imperfect
competition we talked about imperfectly
competitive markets government policy
can make things better what I'll do in
the next two lectures talk about two
other kinds of ration oh I'm sorry
so it's for garage metals we talked
about a perfect competition obviously
this redistribution is another rationale
for govern we talked about that last
time - if we think that social welfare
is increased by redistributing from rich
to poor despite some likud so we've
covered two roles there's fixing
imperfect markets and there's
redistribution in the next two lectures
talk about two other roles for
government and if it's wets your
appetite you want to learn more you can
take 1441 which is of course all about
public policy you can learn a lot more
but we'll talk about two other reasons
today we're going to talk about
externalities which is another
justification for government involvement
and we're going to dive right in with an
example so well that's what what's an
externality an externality occurs
whenever the actions of one party impact
another party in a way for which the
first party does not receive the costs
and benefits so if my actions impact you
but I don't where the costs if they're
negative actions or the benefits of the
positive actions
than that's an externality so anytime
one parties actions affect another party
but the first part is not reads receive
you the costs or the benefits of that
impact that's an externality let's start
with the standard theory example okay
we've the standard examples teach
exercise is the example the steel plants
dumping sludge in a river so imagine
somewhere in America there's a steel
plant located on a river and they
produce steel and the production process
has a certain production function and
one features production functions for
every unit of steel produced a unit of
sludge a liter of waste is produced and
the steel plate dumps that into the
river so just given the nature of their
production process 1u2 field was one you
two sludge is dumped in the river now
let's imagine that down this river
there's a set of fishermen and these
fishermen make their living fishing in
the river and that when the steel plant
dumps sludge in the river
it floats downriver and kills their fish
kill some of their fish okay now it's
the classic example what we call a
negative production externality its
production in the sense it's coming from
the supply side it's coming from the the
production of the steel it's producing
this externality it's negative because
it's negatively impacting the fishermen
down the stream and it's an externality
because the steel plant doesn't give a
[ __ ] okay they dumped their sludge it
goes down to kill some but they don't
bear the cost of doing so the fisherman
bear the cost to do a personality
because the fish because the plant dumps
the sludge force officially to where the
consequences it's a classic negative
production of negative things bad
products because the country supply side
externality because the cost of one by
another party not by the party being yes
graphically we can analyze that sub like
figure 23 one is the classic extra now
and divert
here we have the market for steel look
at the market for steel because the
production field it generates these
negative externalities see this is the
market for fear
you've got a quantity of steel being
produced and a price of fear standard
market you've got a supply curve in
demand
so in our analysis today and let's say
it's part of the competitive analysis
agency where supply equals demand is at
Point a with a quantity q1 and the price
p1 and we would say that and see welfare
maximizing our perfectly competitive
market what this miss is however is that
the supply curve s is the private
marginal cost that's the cost of the
essenes and the building and the workers
that makes us feel but we as a society
don't just care about the private cost
we care about the social cost we care
about the fact as a sick of a society to
the social welfare function that suppose
your function incorporates both the
steel plant and the picture so we don't
just care about the steel plants cost
and the scenes and the workers we care
about the cost in the fisherman - we
care about social marginal farmers what
are social marginal cost that is private
marginal cost plus the damage done to
the negative externality and what we're
going to do is we just tune that's a
hundred dollars for you to steal for you
where's making that up
we're just assume that every seal unit
produced delivers a hundred dollars in
negative x finale has the fish killed
downstream now that that does not have
I've assumed this constant does not to
be costly to imagine little floods of do
much damage
these young we're slugs does more damage
that be a nonlinear wouldn't you have a
process but to make life easy
imagine every imagine sort of in this
region every unit of steel reefs is a
universe flood that killed 100 all of
the fish okay so these and meanwhile now
on the other hand the demand curve so
the supply curve is the private marginal
cost the main service of private
marginal benefit but in this case that
is the same as the social motivation
because there's no extra mounts from the
consumption of steel
we'll come back in a minute to the
subjects guys but let's tune for a
minute that like my private benefit
students feel society sentence has been
skewed it's not like psychic unique feel
I create some positive energy lecture
okay so the demand curve is both the
private and social multi-vector but the
private marginal cost is below the
social marginal cost the social mores
foster five market cause plus the
externality game now what does this mean
this means that the optimal level of
production from society's perspective is
not point a it's point P from society's
perception incorporating to damage to
the fisherman along with the cost of the
steel plant then the occupants were
those social marks are possible for
equal price equals social marginal
benefit which is point C so from
society's perspective there should be
less steel production okay add in the
mouse to - this is low if you want but
the steel plant doesn't care the steel
plant produces - one they don't care
about some fisherman downstream sooner
but overproduction and a deadweight loss
now here's the key thing about
deadweight loss you talk about their
loss before but here we started a loss
deadweight loss is always drawn with
reference to social marginal benefit
costs players not Friday but deadweight
loss is relative to what's best for
society not special one for to go after
in society
so the deadweight loss is all the units
between q2 and q1 where the social
marginal cost exceeds the social
marginal benefit so for that first unit
to the right of q2 there's a tiny
deadweight loss but as you move further
and farther from q2 q1 the deadweight
loss grows because those in units with
is a bigger and bigger gap between the
social marginal cost and the social
market investment the bottom line is
we're back to the chain of logic the
private steel plant does was privately
options that's where it's private
marginal cost equal to private marginal
benefit that's the point
from a social perspective we care about
social marginal cost for social
motivation though so marginal benefit is
the famous private marginal benefit
example but social marginal cost
includes the cost the fisherman so it's
higher given that it's higher we
socially optimal EEP reduce left feel
okay and therefore we would want less
production now once again there's a lot
of complications here for example what
if we instead of using let's see we just
stop them from polluting well that would
be another way you know there's lots of
competition but for now just assume it's
the way the production function it's
gonna make feel you're gonna see okay so
that that's the outcome that's what we
call a that's how is anybody negative
thruster now externalities can also
happen on the consumption side and the
classes have a negative consumption
action ally is smoking so let's put a
figure 23 - now we have the market for
cigarettes
there's the quantity cigarettes on the
x-axis the price cigarettes on the wire
now here we're going to assume the
private marginal cost or as equal or
social moral conference that is there's
no maybe when they make tobacco
cigarettes they police bowl ignore that
for now okay we're just gonna assume
that there's no pollution from the
production side but on the consumption
side when I smoke a cigarette I do
damage to other people okay
most pernicious most obviously to
secondhand smoke I'm very sensitive to
this right now because my mom's my
wife's mom smokes three packs a day my
wife now is COPD heart coronary
obstructive pulmonary disease or just in
the hospital pneumonia because her mom
smokes three packs a day
and so her lungs ELISA so this is the
definitely negative to subsection a Li
her mom smokes and smoke to the point of
point a where her where her back private
benefit equal to private cost but the
social cost between my wife I like to
think and therefore the song aside the
benefit includes the negative impact on
my wife so this led my wife's mom to
over smoke or in general people over
smoke because they don't account for the
fact that there's damage on other
therefore there is too much smoking
too much smoke into you doesn't account
for the damage on others but in this
case this is not a changed supply curve
it's a reduction the benefit because the
production cigarette hasn't changed it's
just a value consuming cigarette system
cigarettes are less valuable to consume
because you get to join them from
smoking at least some people think it's
enjoyable but offsetting that is the
damage you're doing to others so that's
the shift downwards of the marginal
benefit curve now the social marginal
benefit is below the private marginal
benefit and the new equilibrium is where
the social marginal benefit equals the
social marginal cost okay and therefore
the optimal level of smoking is lower
than what individual privately
yes this is not this I'm gonna come back
to what happens when you depart worse to
be perfectly rational people the first
difference I'll come back to this is
more complicated ultimately this is a
part of the reference information even
before they knew it I'm not saying it's
I'm not saying they're bad people who
think so bees are bad people because
they're doing what's 5 the Optima
there's nothing bad about doing it five
of the outfit but doesn't matter if they
knew or not the point is there to lead
in from a social perspective is too much
okay this is think about the exercises
smoking so for example or you get sick
of your medical costs are higher
actually if you just saw passive smokers
start a lot of fires thousands of people
die every year in Americans fire started
by smokers that's until a possibility
for buying the fire department things
like that smokers are less productive so
firms make less money so they take smoke
breaks and things like that you add all
that up and now that's without
secondhand smoke the promise that guys
hope if you don't know how big that
affected that's what the summers you
make sent a package $2 back
so we just really really hard to measure
and it's really hard to measure partly
because of a really interesting
phenomenon which is you might have come
back to me and said wait a second what
happened to your wife is not an
externality
why would went under what situation
here's a hard question under what set of
assumptions would the damage done to my
wife by her mom smoking not be enough
let's say your mom was still wide
yeah
exactly it's only Senator Boozman for
the cost but as a mom knew that by
smoking this would be information
something new that by smoking she'd make
her daughter sick and chose to smoke
anyway then it's not next finale in that
case in the marginal benefits for the
mom would be included the damage done to
the daughter so what's really doing
externalities of is not a strictly easy
thing to measure it depends on now
so fishermen downtown floods down the
river that's different but here the
externality is only true as a mom
seeking account so the key thing the key
question have to ask a judge is do
families maximize a family utility
function or an individual utility
function if her mom was max on your
individual ragam like if she was
measuring if she was just focusing on
her individual utility then she should
just consider the benefits were smoking
for his the cost intact cigarette but if
she's maximizing family utility do you
think the benefit earth smoking - the
damage goes for daughters
versus the cost effective yeah
well know that you're soon I mean you
care about the poignancy now basically
the interesting question is in other
words it's just about wait let's say I
wanted to you are purchasing the
function I don't care about anywhere my
family a whole family's only function I
treat them as if they're myself I give
up usually to the mom where do people
lie in between now in fact there's some
evidence on this and the evidence is
basically that women care about their
families in Windows so there's actually
a number of studies developing countries
there's a cool way to test them and the
way you tack this is you say if family
total emasculation holds then it
shouldn't matter who controls the
resources in the family if I take a
dollar from a wife and give it to a
husband that shouldn't change anything
because we're both maximizing family so
much but if there's individual sylheti
function the new controls for resources
will determine how the money gets spent
there's a quite a striking example from
the UK where they had a tax break for
children and it used to be what happened
this is back in the 7th used to me that
what happened was for every child in the
household at the end of the year check
that sense of the house okay
well typically women were home and
control the money in the house so the
women got that right then change the law
and said no instead we're just going to
let state take home pay a bit higher so
instead of saying techniques here each
week will include in your take-home pay
well the take-home pay went to the men
then we're working women work so it's
shifted from women controlling the money
to mention formulas and what they found
was this ship led to much less being
spent on children's clothes and books
and much more being present alcohol and
tobacco which is inconsistent with a
family function repetition okay
the bottom line is we don't have a
perfect game until you function probably
you have a perfectly busy once you
divide people kissed someone about their
family but as long as kind of perfectly
family silly functions then there's some
extra now we have family members
affected the $0.40 is fully too low we
just go in the house okay now
externalities don't have to be negative
they can also be positive okay let's
think about a positive consumption and
let's come to UM one of my favorite
people I like talking the state of
kibbutz throwing shade to which is my
neighbor okay I don't get along with my
neighbor at all
and um and basically part of the note
that one of my neighbors because my
neighbor has a tendency to start massive
Lansing projects and then leave them
half done
and just not doing and it's unattractive
and so basically let's imagine that my
neighbor is looking at the outside his
yard you think about the landscaping
thinking what's it works to me to fix
this dirt pile in my yard
what's it worth me to fix the sphere
pile in my life okay
well imagine that the dirt pile will
cost a thousand dollars to call away but
he only gets a hundred dollars of
digitally from work so let's say I get
$500 personally and let's say it's a
silly tree doesn't care about me then
he'll say privately I should move the
dirt pile my benefits are noon so is
$800 my cost of doing so is $1,000 okay
so the cost is about if I won't do it
but so slowly
you should get rid of the dirt pile
because the benefits is decides to even
tritium and the 500 to me so if you
remove the dirt pile there of a positive
externality for him consuming
landscaping services there be a positive
externality which is my increase you so
the opossums assumption that you know
okay so that is you can think of this
big figure 23 - but just flip it now
think of my consumption having a
marginal social benefit in that case
unlike the case of cigarettes where
there's too much consumption now there's
two little consumption landscaping
services by my name is not accounting
for the benefits
nobody come that one minute okay now um
finally there's one last example which
is you can have a positive production
action in the class level positive
structure nationality is researcher
development by companies when companies
who are in deep it benefits them but it
also loses general knowledge and said if
it's everyone including their
competitors as a result if you go back
to figure twenty two twenty three one my
social marginal cost of doing R&D are
actually lower than my private marginal
cost because I'm producing I'm reducing
the I'm reduced I'm producing benefits
for other creatures it's the opposite
dumping sludge machine I'm dumping
ecology okay and that now its benefits
everybody downstream
indeed the estimates are that a dollar
of R&D is worth about twice as much to
society you need to go further to do it
if you'd like to learn more about this
you can see you order my new book
jump-starting America which talks about
how we're gonna make America running run
better again by investing a public R&D I
talk all about it very exciting about
that right now so um so those the kinds
of externalities positive and negative
now the question mani active so what so
these things exist why can't people just
figured out take me and my neighbor's
okay there's an easy solution here I
just go to my neighbor and I take him
towards your bus or Georgian one dollar
he's a dollar better off I'm Georgia $99
level off problem solved
indeed there's a famous economist named
Ron and co-host for suppose that there
is no such thing really as an
externality
because all externalities can be
internalized through private negotiation
so
as long as you keep saying as long as as
well-defined properly so in the case my
name is a well defined property right
he owns the dirt pile so I go to him and
offer money to things to get rid of it
likewise imagine the fisherman owns the
river they can then go to the steel
plant and say we are going to charge you
for dumping sludge into the river and
we'll charge you enough so that your
private costs go to the Social Fund
so basically tow said there's no problem
there's no need for government the
private market is here well that's a
really cute argument in theory but in
fact the breakstep because think about
that argument for the biggest exercise I
think the whooping ancient mobile one
okay mobile warming happens because I
Drive my car
he's on dangerous ground how much how
they supposed to come to me and say John
should drive less I'm gonna pay you to
drive left so I don't drown that's crazy
right it doesn't work for big
externality those who wants a little
externalities well think about yourself
say think about your neighbor playing
music see less class you you have a 1401
test the next day your neighbor son was
finals their party is playing the music
too loud that's a classic negative
externality on you now I'm principal you
should say well I consider how much it's
worth to me and I'll pay them turn the
music down there's a famous story about
an economist chemistry books a wonderful
story who was on a plane trying to get
worked on the perspective wouldn't stop
talking so you offer them five bucks to
set up now that that would be the
coaching solution but in reality life
doesn't work that way
so in fact the private markets unlike
going to solve these kinds of bum kind
of problem yeah
that's another nothing on the problem
there's water there's no way you can
close bless your soul would not think
the physician's office okay so that
means we needs a big bad government you
need government seizes because the
private market has failed the private
market has failed because the scribe at
equilibrium is not welfare maximizing
okay so if you go back to twenty two
three one the private market has failed
because the private market overproduces
here therefore there is a role for the
government sanction fixes marketers it
doesn't mean the government will okay
this is the key thing is I just in my
course the waves about the logic of
government involvement economies do two
steps one is is there a market failure
that is will the private market fail to
maximize welfare and two is ten the
government actually make it better
post making it work so just because
prime market failure doesn't mean as a
role for the government it means as a
potential role for today well let's talk
about senior ethically what the
government might do and then factoring
with the government actually goes
through so theoretically the government
is two options the first option is
regulation so go into figs are 23 one
the government's of someone to say hey
steel plants we've done the math and
your optimal levels steel production is
to two so produced we're not cut it
we're going to not we're going to
regulate you if they can't produce for
the future and the government did that
we would get to the optimal outcome the
government said I'm setting up Maxo q2
then we get the optimal outcome which is
to to do for you the problem with that
is exactly the problem we talk about
regulating monopoly which is that
requires a huge amount of government
information they need to know the shapes
and supplied me to those shapers of my
curve the shape is the demand curve and
the size the externality we built all
three things they fly demand in the
sides externality in order
that right and if you get it wrong they
could lead to if they get to own they
get stuck down a steel plant that's
still close to be valuable to have
running but we have this conversation
that linked with monocular education all
the same problems arising
that's why condom is typically prefer a
simple equation which is taxation or
what we call an economic corrective
taxes and this is exciting because when
I took when I talk taxes last time in
the time before taxes cause deadweight
loss taxes cause inefficiency but
actually in the case of externalities
taxes can reduce deadweight loss how's
that let's put a finger 23:3 back to the
steel market imagine
I don't know supply and demand curve I
just know the size the externality it's
$100 at spirit of fear so I simply go to
the steel plant and say look for every
unit of steel you produce I'm gonna
charge you $100 you do what you want I
don't know where you get enough but I
charge you $100 that means that the
steel plant is the steel plant private
marginal cost curve will now align with
the social marginal cost right you've
essentially done what Coast wanted us to
do you've internalized hips and alleys
but dollars of government action rather
than private Association you said you're
imposing a social cost above me on your
private car we are going to essentially
make you consider it's like in your
family's daily function we're gonna make
you consider all society a decision or
make you internalize the damage you're
imposing the decisions we're going to
turn allows that it's by charging you
for the extra cost of imposing on
society so that is what we call
corrective taxation
okay and corrective taxation leads to
the Optima laptops if we stay in a steel
plant for every unit you produce we're
not going to catch you by the map MD
which is the marginal damage then it
leaves them can actually choose point B
which is confusing cuz it would point to
see on the other dress okay
the choose Point C which is the optimal
which is the optimal outcome it will
cause them to choose the optimal outcome
okay so we've essentially got the
private market to do the right thing by
forcing them to turn Eliza personality
much a toast would hoping to happen
subscribe to negotiation we've caused to
happen like why do you think of the same
thing with smoking so go back to figure
23 to imagine i levy the tax of 40 cents
a pack on cigarettes then the marginal
benefit of smoking was followed by 40
cents my willingness to pay memories
oxidize taxes they might when we send
your taxes since we shift down with a
man for tax on consumers it lowers my
willingness to pay
I'm only now only pay 40 cents left to
pack to decide to pay 40 cents in packs
of attack that ships my demand curve
down such the private marginal benefit
Alex waits the closer motivation food no
more smoking so here's the crazy thing
taxes have now where you remove the
deadweight loss tax I'm afraid of the
deadweight loss actually route
deadweight loss so in a perfectly
competitive market with no market
failure taxes trees everyone but once
there's market failure and that's the
theoretical case for for our for
government or for government relations
theoretically the government can make
things better for imposing corrected
yeah like if it's from the it's really
in elapsing yes so basically the way
elasticity plays into it now if they're
totally inelastic you'd have to work
something
but nothing's ever perfect but
essentially you could take this diagram
and and essentially no I'm sorry no let
me back up I said that incorrectly big
breakfast elasticity doesn't matter for
the awful government policy all I want
to do is impose the size get tsunami
okay if the man is inelastic that
suddenly people love smoking and as a
result you won't reduce smoking that
much but that's okay because baseball we
care about correcting the externalities
okay we're not trying to punish smokers
what I'm trying to achieve an optimal
and back from the difference between
regulation taxation regulation says no I
know what the right little cookies I'm
gonna impose a taxation look I don't
throw a lovely smoking it they people
freaking love smoking imagine those
extra knows to consumption influence
that's one thing no less insulin because
the one things no we have to have a
tongueless inform we say no we should
tax even for their sounds be impose but
if they so choose to do a lot of
influence then they're still doing the
socially optimal decision the really
good questions are the highlights the
key nature here if this is why this
framework furnishing was very
controversy with environmental advocates
environmental advocates heated different
but they're like they called it a
pollution absolution guess what
absolution is it the sing it these are
these are up monks used to give before
Martinez came along before in the church
back in the 1400s
monks and come along and say yeah I know
you sin but to give me like like one one
point or whatever I'll say your sins
will absolve Susie monthly sort of
bribes you can get into heaven okay so
that's so for many is this blue snap
solution environment of safest way think
about they're like wait your legs you'll
pay to get out of the damage they're
doing and the answer is yes the right
thing to do because in fact if people
pay and don't change their behavior that
means they just
doing that activity and watching teen
Elias I'm just cuz they loved you in
that activity which is penalized them to
the sense they're hurting others not
care about the enjoyment they get so
people for some reason just love smoking
let me smoke but making account for the
damage you do the other
great question
okay let me talk that's a great segue
I'll talk about now which is let's move
from theory to practice let's talk about
actual government power and what
governments do and how its swarmed by
this country okay let's start with
environmental external the plastic piece
the classic case of negative solution
environment okay so if I'm in our size
for example when produce electricity the
emissions from live electricity the
chauffeur and the nitrous oxide sulfur
dioxide nitrous oxide go into the air
they form particulate switch get in our
lungs and cause us to get sick it cause
acid rain which falls in a rose forests
and buildings and things like that and
then of course we have global warming
which is the single biggest issue facing
maybe not you almost certainly your kids
and definitely there's a probably not
you like your kids when they're old and
your grandkids for sure
which is it basically um the amount of
fossil fuels we burn is exploded we now
and the amount of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere is now the high for 2000
years and by estimates including from
the Trump administration this will lead
to massive warming of the earth and by
the year 2100 global temperatures could
rise as much as 10 degree family now for
those of you from North Dakota that
might not sound so bad right now I'm
boss but basically the truth is it's
very bad because basically it leads to
enormous rises in sea levels by as much
as potentially as 3 C and um you know
just think about that that means for
example Bangladeshis Cape Cod gone New
York City launches on Florida's on
they face America becomes a sort of
Midwest okay basically uh essentially
you've got you've got um and in putting
economic terms the Trump administration
calculation suggests the u.s. to be 10
percent for by 2100 as a result of the
real but it's a classic finality because
it's the ultimate externality because
every single time you drive you
contribute to it and you can in every
single time someone in Australia drives
they can see because it all just goes in
the air mixes together and creates one
level of global warming since a
completely global externalities any
pollution emissions anywhere has the
same effect and the effect is very
different in in space so if you're in
Minnesota the effect is not nearly
status you're in Bangladesh it's it's it
in time because the effects in the way
in the future not on you it's a classic
externality because the effect truly
don't affect you and they arise from
your consumption what
oh yeah well it's not the time part is
only is what makes of a tectonic today
as long as when I Drive I do not take
any extra cost for the mark avenge on
these new buyers benefit internet
doesn't matter if it's in effect now in
the future okay
the bottom line is when you drive you
are slightly making the environment work
okay you live in that environment but
the problem is you particularly here in
Boston aren't going to feel next so the
consequence is global warming at least
initially so you're right if you went to
your own little world
that's a great three-point number
exercise if you bury these heels you
know own little world where you drove
and they joined the rain cloud by
Charlie Brown and it like and it like
you covered all the conflicts that it
wouldn't be acting out but the truth is
sets off for many many people now how do
you think about discounting when the
damage is 100 years from now so let's
say you took a standard interest rate
may increase or low resources
well so true that a hundred years from
now that means damages are worth like
twenty percent of what they're worth
today at a higher de cerveza what's
affected in hero Basin saying if you
have any form of discount of an original
magnitude basically your great rankings
don't matter today let's be sort of
implausible so there's a lot of people
work on sort of multi-generational
discounting how do we think about
discounting for hazards which are way
way off in the future now turns out he
would reasonable discount rates you
process the fuse today because they're
so enormous future even discount them
back that's still big today but that's
the kind of difficult issue really
exciting interesting stuff so what do we
do well in Europe they've gone the
taxation rep for Jack a gallon of gas in
France was $7.00 McCrone is just
proposed increasing the tax and it's
project hours to burn ironically
but um it's typically in Europe that
leaves many many times more expensive
the US and basically they have Farben
taxes they try to control it but it's
proved very difficult to that and you
have to be when bill clinton opposed the
threesome bathroom first elected in the
gas tax are very hard to imposing yes so
that's why there's been a move toward a
way from a taxation approach towards a
regulation even though regulation
approaches have the other weaknesses
there's been a move towards trying to
cap global emissions trying to regulate
a cap of global emissions and this began
with the first agreement was negotiated
Kyoto in 1997 97 I was at that Houston
pool I was part of the clinton
ministration delegation that went over
there and think about how hard this is
free to negotiate so let's say you're
india you come in you say wait a second
a nice eclipse in 1997 of all the stuff
in the air the u.s. is responsible for
about 30 percent and the rest the world
combined the seventy Senate even said
wait a second we haven't done anything
in the environment okay we're ready to
grow we want to earth conditions we want
our cars you want and you say you says
now wait a second I can't have back as
we stood up being by are you okay you
guys screwed up you guys think it's a
pretty hard the negotiation yes do
what's the cost of quite laws so it's
actually pretty cool I was there for I
was there for four days I slept four
hours and Japan they have this cool
coffee in a can you just put a live on
and we negotiated agreement which was
not going to solve the problem was to
slow the growth of it but America was
never actually went to ratify these
heavily fast forward to 20 years later
to three years ago and terrace we sat we
signed another climate agreement called
the Paris climate force
which was similar to Kyoto and the set
targets the countries to meet and we
were successful at more countries
participated in Kyoto comes like Indian
Chinese in four different but now most
countries are participated in the Paris
agreement limiting emissions the u.s. in
that case find it
but now the troubled ministration in
fact often they're not as conservative
now you can completely understand
politically why a leader would not want
to enforce the agreement like this
you're imposing pain today for the
benefits of people you'll never even
meet okay first of all they live in
other countries by enlarge second of all
in the 100 years so politically is is
unbelievably challenging but the problem
is by the time those people are drowning
it's too late okay basically even if
today the but if sudden stop using any
fossil fuel today let's say phony
something any possible today
temperatures would still rise for
something like 300 years before they
start to follow me I think so basically
this is an incredibly hard problem
because that he cost us to Perdition the
benefits of pictures who didn't accost
my post today and that's a very very
hard problem that's why this is why the
single biggest local problem facing the
world over the next hundred years is how
do we deal with economics in the answer
is easy I mean it says what to do with
easy you post tax or regulation useless
you essentially phased out of seeing the
fossil fuel based economy okay so
theoretically is no problem the problem
is all political which is basically how
do you get usually learning to Bader the
cost in the near-term Nevada State and
that's just anymore Michelle yeah
well got to be questioned about the
nature especially essentially there's a
different area where they have more
faith in the government to be doing yes
maybe that's because you're settled by
frontier adventurous teaching he's never
likes you told what to do I don't quite
know what it is but in any case there's
a different attitude before government
in general and I think essentially think
of a social welfare function which he
thought everybody say but everyone needs
a whole future with some form of
discount you've gotta trust that social
welfare function this is the government
but look I don't want to minimize how
hard this is okay there's just there's a
normative agreement about how fast we
should go many of in fact I was
originally one of these I went to Kyoto
is the autonomous equivalent station
were opposed how strict the Kyoto
targets were severe actually the very
first spam attack I got stand by
hundreds that that points the enormous
of environmental activists saying how
terrible I was because I didn't want to
restrict emissions no okay basically
this huge disagree in this but it
becomes 150 to top of the canopy it's a
critical problem likewise another
critical source of externalities now we
talked about smoking but there's lots of
extra knowledge so smoking the extra
nodes are actually not that large forty
cents a pack is not that large potential
you secondhand smoke so bring that to
drinking the access our drinking are
enormous because drunk drivers guilty
okay indeed um there are 13,000 deaths
per year
these were the correct incorrect let me
say it that is for 9/11 every year from
people drunk drivers
400,000 people are injured every year
that's a classic analogy if I kill
someone in my car made my life people to
take it away but clearly I'm not bearing
the full pots of killer
that's a great question I'm trying to
compress my home courts in one luxury
cigars but there is there are estimates
of value like typically we say a life
worth about ten minutes but basically
you take those valuations the
externalities from drunk driving or
enormous and yet we have very very low
taxes on out yeah great great quite
disease we could go all the other
absolutely they are and this is like
nobody likes economist for example we
think sages lies aren't worth as much as
your life is your life so kind of an
evil ok so there's all sorts of
interesting and difficult issues in
valuing life the whole field but in any
case the bottom line is since White's
valuable ok there is a great um there is
there is an important externality
now let's come to the interesting case a
phrase hop-hop which is illegal drugs
now let's think about cigarettes per day
cigarettes impose externalities but I
never said the answer with the fancy or
make them illegal I said the answer was
to tax them so lets them to properly
measure secondhand smokes or whatever we
do it indeed so thanks indeed cigarette
taxes today probably see any of these
were that you know I'm one of the
biggest things I hope you have a good
outfit and I would admit bigger
attackers today which average national
several dollars a pack probably easy
that's the analysis moreover going to
legal drugs we don't attack that we
think so we simply in all safeties and
marijuana
we still ban all you know other drugs
everywhere
what think about it the framework that's
what you so far does not say should ban
anything if I love doing cocaine we
should taxes the extra miles I do indeed
let's go further
there aren't any extra now the most
illegal oh okay sighs you cocaine
they may get car accidents or heroin but
they largely to kill themselves they
don't do a lot of sorts of it enlarges
kill themselves indeed of you what are
the exercise of illegal drugs they come
from fighting illegal drugs it's the
crime the comfort of the drugs are
illegal okay that's the biggest that
I've come drugs so without using
economists for decades have are these
drugs should be legal ultra but if you
think about it they should be legal and
tax because the externalities more to
come to the fact is they're illlegal you
think about all the jacks in Mexico you
know what would happen in Mexico
if drugs are legal in America [ __ ]
the prices collapse the cartels what
I've no money to make and they break up
and there would be all these deaths the
next day those deaths the next one are
on us it's on the US consumers who
demand was illegal good for Mexico that
creates demand for priming medicine
price drugs illegal so why not legalize
drugs well you'll never one minute so
the answer is because these don't think
this model applies also to fix the
particular we don't think people always
they dragged over see in this framework
to see rational decision we think that
people make mistakes and if the mistakes
are severe enough then taxation is not
the right answer using that right there
okay and that's why that's why we say
look we think that people most people
try illegal drugs at one time they're 18
we think the people before they're 18
are not police don't have fully swarm
prefrontal cortexes and I probably that
they get addicted and that has lifelong
consequences therefore we make the drug
illegal because we think the cost those
clusters are so large that we don't take
a chance but that raises the whole
debate that you all we have that
marijuana legally is that suze now I
want the X 2000 I want are really small
okay
indeed the damage in yourself is
actually pretty small much less than
smoking so how do we think about whether
marijuana to be legal or illegal versus
cocaine and heroin and how much could be
taxed so that's the kind of spending to
see if you do way we talk about this so
anyway find that more interesting take
1441 will spend many lectures talking
about